- So huge news involving Rudy Giuliani.
Apparently the Department
of Justice has executed
a search warrant and searched his files.
It's hard to overstate
just how extraordinary of a step this is.
The Department of Justice
doesn't like executing
search warrants against lawyers
and especially against
lawyers of a former president.
It was extraordinary when
it happened to Michael Cohen
and it's doubly
extraordinary when it happens
to Rudy Giuliani.
This is allegedly related
to Giuliani's efforts
to illegally lobby on behalf of Ukrainians
and potentially Russians
and surprise surprise,
there are reports that the Trump DOJ tried
to quash this investigation
only to have new Attorney
General Merrick Garland remove
the objections.
Whether this is the start of prosecutions
against former Trump officials
or just something related to
Giuliani remains to be seen,
but we'll see you in court.